y
[Música]
el nuevo presidente de eeuu afronta su
primer día en la casa blanca en las
primeras horas de su gobierno firmó 17
órdenes ejecutivas que dan un giro a las
políticas de su predecesor donald trump
en temas como el cambio climático la
protección de migrantes el regreso a la
o ms y la justicia racial en el país
la oms se celebra el regreso de eeuu el
médico anthony fauci delegado por joe
biden ante la organización señaló esta
mañana que se sumará al proyecto de la
plataforma kóvacs para llevar vacunas a
todo el mundo y que saldará el
compromiso financiero de la unión
americana con el organismo
el continente americano a través de un
recrudecimiento de la pandemia que
agrava la situación hospitalaria según
advirtió la organización panamericana de
la salud frente al alza de los contagios
y el temor por la propagación de las
nuevas variantes del coronavirus los
países latinoamericanos avanzan
lentamente con la vacunación panamá se
convirtió en el sexto país de la región
en iniciar su campaña
hola cómo están bienvenidos a las
noticias aquí en france24 soy alan a
austria empezamos en estados unidos el
país amanece con nuevo presidente y
vicepresidenta ya instalados en la casa
blanca- joe biden firmó una serie de
órdenes ejecutivas para revertir las
políticas del mandato de donald trump
mientras que la vicepresidenta kamala
harris en la cámara alta juramento a los
tres nuevos senadores demócratas
informada luís muñoz
a sus 78 años finalmente joe biden
disfrutó de su primer día en la oficina
más poderosa del mundo tras el protocolo
de la inauguración como presidente
empezó el trabajo
estoy orgulloso de las acciones
ejecutivas de hoy comenzaré por cumplir
las promesas que le hice al pueblo
estadounidense es un largo camino por
recorrer son acciones ejecutivas y son
importantes pero vamos a necesitar mucha
legislación en su primer día vayan firma
una serie de órdenes ejecutivas
revirtiendo políticas de la
administración trump y tomando nuevas
decisiones destaca la vuelta de eeuu al
acuerdo climático de parís ya la
organización mundial de la salud un
mayor esfuerzo contra el kobe 19 fin a
la prohibición de viajar a países de
mayoría musulmana protecciones para los
beneficiarios del programa daca y un
proyecto de ley que busca ofrecer un
camino a la ciudadanía para 11 millones
de indocumentados
jens aquí secretaria de prensa de la
casa blanca desveló cómo será la gestión
de la migración y la prioridad del
presidente reflejada en la orden es
manejar responsablemente la frontera
mantener a las familias unidas
incentivar el crecimiento económico
atender las causas de la migración desde
centroamérica y asegurarse de que eeuu
seguirá siendo un refugio para aquellos
que huyen de la persecución
además va a ir en firmó el fin de la
declaración de emergencia que servía
para dotar de fondos la construcción del
muro entre eeuu y méxico y órdenes para
impulsar la igualdad justicia racial y
la defensa de las minorías tampoco
perdió el tiempo en su primer día la
vicepresidenta kamala harris
harris juró a tres nuevos miembros
demócratas los dos obtenidos en georgia
además de alex padilla primer senador
latino por california que ocupará el
escaño de la vicepresidenta en el senado
a pesar de que demócratas y republicanos
cuentan con 50 senadores harris tendrá
el voto clave que decantara las
decisiones
tras la jura la primera votación del
senado donde se confirmó a abril heinz
como secretaria de inteligencia el
médico anthony fauci el ahora
representante de eeuu ante la uc anunció
esta mañana que el gobierno de joe biden
va a saldar sus compromisos financieros
con la organización mundial de la salud
y se sumará a la plataforma kóvacs que
busca garantizar un reparto equitativo
de las vacunas contra el cob y 19 en
todo el mundo el director general de esa
organización pedrosa danón consideró que
el regreso estadounidense es un gran día
organismo y para la salud mundial
y es que la llegada a la casa blanca de
joe biden fue celebrada por líderes de
otras naciones y es vista como una
oportunidad de reconstruir relaciones
michael shifter presidente de la
organización diálogo interamericano
analizó para france24 los retos
estadounidenses para volver al
multilateralismo y dejar atrás las
políticas del américa first
bueno ya inicio algunos mensajes muy
claros firmó el regreso a eeuu al
tratado de parís sobre el tema de cambio
climático que es un tema urgente para
administración byron y también la
organización reincorporarse como miembro
de la organización mundial de salud
estos son sólo señales me parece que son
muy claras y muy importantes indiquen
que va a ser el rumbo del presidente
baile quieres reconstruir las alianzas
del mundo que se había debilitado en los
últimos cuatro años cuando eeuu andaba
solo por el mundo y retiro y en muchos
mecanismos o laterales yo creo que esto
va a surgir muy importante
el presidente joe biden tiene el reto de
retomar los lazos con américa latina'
ahora ya desde su inicio el no
mandatario quiere marcar diferencia
frente a throne con una mayor apertura
este es el informe de juán pupiales
que las deportaciones no sean una
prioridad es un cambio que llega desde
el primer día de la administración va a
ir en el nuevo presidente apuesta por
reforzar el programa daca que blinda a
cientos de miles de migrantes que
llegaron a la unión americana cuando
eran niños es un plan que tiene en la
mira al presidente mexicano andrés
manuel lópez obrador que ha pedido a su
homólogo job aid en una reforma
migratoria esto en medio del fenómeno de
las caravanas que llegan desde
centroamérica ya el nuevo departamento
de seguridad nacional anunció una
moratoria de 100 días en algunas
deportaciones para asegurar una
aplicación efectiva de estas medidas si
creemos que este va a ser el año de la
reforma migratoria
nosotros estamos sacando hoy en día una
carta abierta al presidente by day up
porque estamos pidiéndole que cumpla la
promesa de esta reforma migratoria la
política migratoria de washington es una
preocupación general en américa latina
pero cada país tiene sus propios
intereses en colombia el gobierno había
contado con el apoyo del ex presidente
de dawn trump para retomar su política
de las aspersiones con glifosato para
hacer frente a unas cifras récord de
cultivos de hoja de coca en brasil jair
bolsonaro se queda sin un aliado
importante con la salida de trump
mientras tanto el presidente de
venezuela nicolás maduro espera que haya
un punto de inflexión yo llamo para que
el nuevo gobierno de eeuu
supere la demonización que han hecho de
la revolución bolivariana del comandante
chávez de nicolás maduro
y pase la página
otro aspecto clave en las relaciones con
américa latina es la economía china es
hoy en día el primer socio comercial de
brasil chile perú uruguay argentina el
gigante asiático además ha aprovechado
la pandemia para estrechar sus lazos con
la región con la venta de suministros
como los ventiladores y las mascarillas
en bagdad al menos 28 personas murieron
y más de 70 están heridas en un doble
atentado provocado por dos atacantes que
se hicieron explotar en un mercado
popular en la céntrica plaza alta y eran
nuestra corresponsal en teherán catalina
gómez ángel nos dio detalles de estos
ataques en bagdad
el ataque de esta mañana en bagdad se
llevó a cabo en una de las plazoletas
más céntricas y más concurridas de la
ciudad con un gran bazar que suele ser
bastante visitado especialmente en horas
de las mañanas las autoridades hablan de
dos hombres suicidas con cinturones
llenos de explosivos que habrían
realizado el ataque el primero se habría
hecho el enfermo lo que hizo que varias
personas se acercaran a ayudarlo en ese
momento se explotó luego vinieron otros
a ayudar a los heridos lo que hizo que
el segundo se explotara nuevamente lo
que hizo que este atentado tuviera esta
gran magnitud las defensas civiles los
militares hablan de 28 muertos y 70
heridos pero se cree que la cifra puede
aumentar en las próximas horas el último
gran atentado que había visto bagdad
había sido en este mismo lugar en enero
de 2018 cuando ya se había declarado la
victoria contra el llamado estado
islámico o isis que todavía tiene
células en el país que han venido
haciendo ataques en algunos lugares muy
concretos no en la capital y aunque
ellos no se han reclamado la autoría
todas las miradas van hacia ellos
la nueva variante de coronavirus que se
originó en reinounido se ha encontrado
en 60 países y regiones señaló la o ms
mientras que la detectada en sudáfrica
ha sido reportada en 23 regiones en el
continente americano la pandemia se
agrava con la mitad de los contactos
mundiales en la última semana ante el
colapso en manaus brasil por la falta de
tubos de oxígeno que provocó la muerte
de decenas de personas se espera la
llegada de unos 136 mil metros cúbicos
de oxígeno desde venezuela por su parte
panamá se convirtió en el sexto país de
la región en iniciar su campaña y
ecuador- se perfila como la próxima
nación en comenzar su vacunación la ope
se advierte de la situación hospitalaria
en américa latina'
en toda nuestra región especialmente en
américa del norte y del sur muchos
hospitales están funcionando al límite
de su capacidad o muy cerca de este
vehículo
llegamos al final de esta emisión les
agradecemos mucho su compañía los
invitamos a seguir con información al
momento en nuestro sitio web y también
en nuestra señal televisiva tenga un
excelente día y cuídense cuídense mucho
del comit y sener
[Música]